[Music]
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
this is built on their shoulders
[Music]
no I ain't sounding an autograph but you
get off my car you don't remember me huh
[Music]
Damien foreign
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but
kept myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
who cares what happened with you too I
didn't tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though man I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
oh
you don't always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad try spending half your
life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
that mean was like family
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me traumatic stress watching manifest
got my only fear I ain't scared of death
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah
foreign